[Música]
[Aplausos]
esta mañana cuando abriste tu closet
para elegir lo que ibas a poner te
preguntaste qué porcentaje de toda la
ropa que tú tienes no utilizas
cuántas personas quisieran tener la ropa
que nunca lleva expuesta
hace algunos años el día de mi
cumpleaños alguien toca la puerta de mi
cuarto
al abrir veo a mi mamá con una gran
sonrisa
llevaba un regalo para mí en su mano
derecha era la camisa roja de manga
corta con flores multicolor que habíamos
visto ella y yo el jueves pasado en el
centro comercial cuando hicimos nuestra
tardeada mamá hija
han pasado 25 años y esta camisa que
tanto adoro sigue en mi closet
me ha seguido de parís a cancún ida y
vuelta en mis días de felicidad de enojo
y de tristeza
y hoy en día esa camisa sigue en micro
sets en muy buenas condiciones
bien podría haber pensado en comprar una
nueva camisa para contribuir a que la
industria textil siga siendo la segunda
más contaminante de nuestro planeta
después del petróleo
o comprar una nueva camisa y ya estar
más de dos mil litros de agua en
producirla es la cantidad de agua que
una persona bebe durante dos años y
medio es muchísima agua para una sola
camisa imagínense cuánto representa para
todas las prendas que tienen en su
closet
y ni les hablo del desarrollo de la fase
fashion o moda rápida que no se hace
consumir siempre más y más textil o de
los sueldos edades o condiciones
laborales de quienes de quienes producen
este textil
podría haber pensado que esta camisa
vieja no le sirve a nadie y haberla
tirado a la basura como me cuenta que lo
hace en mi técnico del aire
acondicionado cuando ya no le sirve su
ropa
piensan que es un caso aislado
pues no
imagínate sólo el 15 por ciento de la
ropa a nivel mundial es donada o
reciclada
eso significa que 9 de cada 10 personas
cierra su textil a la basura
para que te des cuenta en méxico cada
año 640 millones de toneladas de desecho
textil terminan a la basura
eso corresponde a una tonelada cada
minuto
cada mexicano en promedio en un año
tiene 200 camisetas a la basura
es tanto el textil que tiramos en méxico
cada año que alcanza para rellenar dos
veces el estadio azteca con capacidad de
87 mil personas
y una vez llegando al relleno sanitario
mi camisa de poliéster hubiera tardado
500 años en degradarse igual que una
bolsa de plástico del súper
cuando pensamos en reciclar pensamos en
papel cartón metal pero quien piensa en
reciclar el textil que nos ayuda a
disminuir el volumen de desechos que
mandamos a los rellenos sanitarios o
reducir la energía consumida fomenta el
desarrollo de productos reciclados y la
economía responsable y generar nuevos
empleos
recicla la ropa pero para quién
sabías que en méxico 4 de cada 10
mexicanos viven en estado de pobreza o
extrema pobreza
y la zona urbana de cancún no es un caso
aislado
el estado de quintana roo cuenta con una
infinidad de comunidades mayas muy
retiradas de las zonas urbanas donde los
servicios básicos son escasos y las
visitas de apoyo social son mínimas son
personas muy humildes que viven del día
al día para ellos complacer ropa nueva o
usada representa un enorme gasto en el
presupuesto familiar y la mayoría de
ellos no pueden comprar para ropa para
su familia
el hecho de donarles una prenda les
agregará el día y el de su familia bien
podrían recibir un pantalón y darle otro
uso transformándolo en shorts por
ejemplo oa una camisa cortarle la manga
corta y utilizar ese desecho textil para
hacer trapos para limpiar su casa
unas amigas expertas en feng shui me
dijeron que al desprendernos de esas
cosas que no necesitamos en ese momento
creamos el vacío y el vacío genera
oportunidades y cosas buenas de nuestra
vida otra amiga me recomendó leer el
libro la magia del orden de dow
y aplicar el método con mario' que
consiste en decir cuida tus cosas y
cuando ya no te hacen feliz dona las
despídete de ellas agradeciendo su
función
y ahí es cuando realmente entendí
más allá del plan esta camisa todos los
días de abril micro sets la relación que
tenía con ella el aun real apego
emocional a esa ropa sólo me faltaba ser
el duelo de esta camisa el duelo de las
emociones de las experiencias que sentí
de las memorias que se matarían llevaba
en sí
todos en algún momento de nuestra vida
hemos donado algo a alguien ese objeto
esa planta que tanto nos gustaba pero
realmente pensamos en que iba a ser la
persona que lo reciba o que el segundo
uso le iba a dar a ese objeto que le
dimos
esta camisa me la compro mi mamá hace 25
años
la puse del día después de la fiesta de
mi primera comunión
el día que mi hermano se grado
y también sin querer
el día que le diagnosticaron un cáncer a
mi mamá
mi mamá ya no está
pero esta camisa así
cuando abro mi closet me recuerda a ella
me recuerda de todas las emociones que
ya no puedo compartir con ella
nunca pensé que esa camisa podría hacer
feliz a alguien más como todas las
emociones que me dio a mí a lo largo de
estos años
y ahí es cuando me vino la idea de crear
un espacio de intercambio y convivencia
donde las personas de escasos recursos
puedan de forma personalizada elegir la
ropa que realmente necesitan para su uso
personal
una tienda sin precios
y así surge la idea de la tiendita
gratuita
sí
es una tienda sin precios nuestros
beneficiarios se sorprenden al llegar y
encontrar un espacio igual que su tienda
de ropa habitual
con ropa que huela ropa limpia que huela
rico dividirá por secciones hombres
mujeres niños accesorios y donde
realmente pueden elegir lo que necesitan
para su uso personal pero sin etiquetas
y sin precios cuando les explicamos el
concepto se sorprenden y vuelven a
preguntar que si realmente estamos
regalando la ropa
y este brillo en sus ojos tampoco tiene
precio
en unas galletas impresos preparamos con
cariño la ropa para restaurar la
autoestima de quien la reciba
en una tiendita de sin precios
permitimos a la gente refleja lo que
tiene en el interior pero por carencias
económicas no lo podía hacer antes
una chinita sin presos también ayuda a
los accidentes de la vida como es el
caso de la señora marisela que nos fue
recomendada por otra asociación porque
se le quemó su cuarto y perdió todo
con nosotros pudo elegir ropa para ella
y su hijo de 10 años en una tienda sin
precios también apoyamos a la iniciación
social como es el caso de don jaime
quien nos vino a visitar para escoger un
saco como él dice para verse mejor para
su entrevista de trabajo en el día
siguiente y qué creen
obtuvo el puesto
una de nuestras beneficiarias la señora
gladys que tiene una prótesis ocular y
por esta discapacidad y su edad le
dificultaba encontrar trabajo
pues ella trabaja con nosotros y nos
ayuda a reciclar la ropa que por su
condición rota o dañada no se puede
donar o reusar ella transforma este
textil usado para poder alargar su ciclo
de vida y desviarlo de la basura unos
años más
por todo ello le damos otro valor al
textil usado un valor más sentimental un
valor más emocional
y tú al donar tu ropa es una forma de
desprenderte de ellas y hacer que
alguien más le dé una segunda vida para
que todas las emociones contenidas en
esta ropa puedan trascender y resonar en
otras manos
qué haces tú a diario para ayudar a las
demás personas que no tienen la suerte
de vivir la vida que tú tienes
qué haces tú para contribuir a una mejor
sociedad
yo no soy mejor que nadie y no vengo a
convencerles de que contribuyamos a una
mejor un mejor mundo o cuidar el medio
ambiente
solo les propongo que hagamos conciencia
de que algo que nos hizo feliz en algún
momento de nuestra vida puede hacer
feliz a alguien más a través de a través
de su reciclaje sin precio
se parte de un cambio
así que ya sabes de forma sencilla
puedes apoyar tanto socialmente como
ambientalmente solo te hace falta
regresa a tu casa
abre tu closet y aquí está transmitir
todas las emociones que estas prendas te
dieron a ti
haz la diferencia recicla tu ropa
a saber
[Aplausos]